en el último vídeo nos quedamos tratando
de descubrir quién es gamma verdad y
obtuvimos esta última ecuación y
teníamos la idea de tomar un evento
particular que correspondía a una señal
luminosa verdad en cuyo caso x era igual
a 7 para las coordenadas de ese evento
pero también tendríamos que x prima es
igual a 7 prima verdad y si gama era el
mismo en el mismo factor verdad para
cualquier transformación entre eventos
en particular debe funcionar para este
evento verdad donde x es igual a cto x
prima es igual a 7 prima y quizás
podríamos utilizar esto sustituirlo en
esta ecuación y encontrar el valor de
gamma así que vamos a sustituir x por 7
vamos a sustituir x por 7 y también x
prima por 7 prima muy bien así que vamos
a hacerlo entonces podemos ver que aquí
en vez de esta x podríamos poner 7 en
lugar de este x podríamos poner 7 y en
lugar de esta x podríamos poner 7 ahora
en lugar de este x prima podríamos poner
7 prima en lugar de este x prima sería 7
prima y en lugar de esta x prima ponemos
7 prima veamos qué es lo que obtenemos
bueno aquí tenemos c por c que es sé
cuadrada y esto x de prima
de prima y esto a quien será igual esto
será igual a gama cuadrada nuestro
factor de lawrence verdad que multiplica
se por sea quien se cuadrada se cuadrada
que multiplica te deprimas t y t prima
muy bien más aquí tenemos se porte por
bt prima sería se porte por bt prima y
luego tendríamos menos ce que multiplica
a t por bt prima verdad aquí tendríamos
esta vez y luego te prime entonces
tenemos de aquí estate y luego ve de
prima de de prima y voy a cambiar el
color aquí para que compares bien con el
sumando anterior y finalmente tenemos
menos b cuadrada que multiplica
y multiplica a t prima muy bien y
cerramos nuestro paréntesis entonces lo
que podemos observar aquí es que este
sumando es exactamente el mismo que este
otro pero tienen signos contrarios eso
significa que podemos cancelar los
verdad ahora bien de los sumandos que
nos quedan todos los sumandos tienen la
digamos el factor t t prima cierto
entonces podemos dividir de ambos lados
entre t t prima y esto se cancela para
este sumando de este factor se cancela y
este otro factor también se cancela
verdad entonces qué es lo que obtenemos
del lado izquierdo tendremos se cuadrada
voy a seguir aquí verdad se cuadrada es
igual
gama cuadrada gama cuadrada que
multiplica a se cuadrada se cuadrada
esto se han cancelado y luego tenemos
menos de cuadrada menos b cuadrada y
cerramos nuestro paréntesis verdad de
aquí simplemente podríamos despejar gama
cuadrada verdad entonces gama cuadrada
digamos ya pasándolo de este lado sería
igual a se cuadrada sería igual si ya lo
voy a hacer sólo con un color muy bien
entonces sería se cuadrada y pasamos
está dividiendo se cuadrada menos de
cuadrada o en otras palabras si por
ejemplo dividimos entre pse cuadrada en
el numerador y en el dom denominador
aquí nos queda uno aquí tendríamos uno
menos de cuadrada sobre se cuadrada muy
bien entonces ya con esto incluso
podríamos dejar que suenen los redobles
porque podríamos calcular explícitamente
quien es nuestro factor
verdad gama simplemente hay que obtener
la raíz cuadrada verdad de esta
expresión que tenemos del lado derecho y
tenemos raíz cuadrada de 1 es uno
dividiendo a la raíz cuadrada de uno
menos b cuadrada sobre c cuadrada muy
bien así que ahí tenemos el valor de
gamma del factor de lawrence así que
espero que todo esto te haya resultado
convincente pues pues de todo lo que
hicimos fue pensar en la asimetría que
había entre estos marcos de referencia
verdad en realidad tomamos la
transformación galileana verdad partimos
de la transformación galileana y luego
la escalamos con un factor gamma y luego
lo hicimos también para el otro marco de
referencia verdad y además usamos el
hecho fundamental de la relatividad
especial de que la velocidad de la luz
es absoluta en cualquiera de los marcos
de referencia verdad entonces lo que
hicimos fue sustituir estas expresiones
verdad y pudimos resolver quién
a gama ahora algunos de ustedes estarán
preguntando qué es lo que ha pasado con
digamos la parte de la transformación de
lawrence correspondiente para ti y te
prima si solo hemos en realidad ha
hablado de las coordenadas xy x prima
verdad entonces ese detalle te dejaré a
ti que lo pienses y que trates de
hacerlo y te daré una pista de cómo
hacerlo solo es que será un poco más
algebraico que lo que hemos hecho hasta
ahora así que de cualquier forma lo
haremos en el próximo vídeo